okay we got a choice we got moment of
truth but we got story time story time
okay story time
all right back to the young days with
young abba all right demon time yoruba i
had this experience one time
i was 17 at a shopping mall there's a
little booth where a woman was selling
cell phones my age looking cute you know
what i'm saying piece you know the type
to being like one of them bt music
videos you know what i mean
i said girl
no no no no no
[Laughter]
girl
[Music]
girl tell me fellas have you seen her so
i see her at the phone booth right
and i go up to her chatter up this is
the time when you had them sliding
phones sorry grab her digits you know
chop it up with her a little bit i'm
like yo listen i want to take you out
for some food on the weekend let's go
watch that cool cool ride because i said
great and at the time i remember how i
used to dress i used to have dicky pants
because [ __ ] was hood for no reason
all right so you always have to wear
dicky pants without any belts and i used
to have long hair and i used to use like
a
nike headband to pull it back right
terrible idea it's not good for your
roots but anyways so
get her number i'm walking through the
mall and then i see this white dude he's
got a wife beater and you know back in
the days like a lot of dudes with those
faux skin head looks yeah where they
like dress kind of scummy yeah but like
hate [ __ ] yeah and he's with his girl
this girl's mean buggy means like he's
giving me look and at the time i was a
bit of a loose cannon right so [ __ ]
looked at me kind of funny i'm walking
through the mall and i said you know
what the [ __ ] you looking at and the guy
said some [ __ ] i don't know what
happened i just snapped i know this i
don't know how i snapped
because i was with my homies and we were
walking so this is us walking like this
right so basically crossing each other
me and my homie were crossing this way
they were crossing this way my homie's
looking at a store like talking
i just run at them i don't want to say
nothing right and i started hitting the
do and when i hit him he had a chain
wrapped around his hand so he started
hitting me he actually broke my nose
that day so we're fighting finally i get
on top and we're on the floor and i'm
punching this dude right 10 feet away
there were two shopping mall security
guards waiting by the escalator
i got in a fight right in front of these
[ __ ] because i was stupid stupid
so as i'm punching this dude right and
i'm on top of him i'm laying on this
[ __ ] all i feel are two hands going
right on my back and i'm flying through
the air i'm talking magic carpet right
okay mitch frizzle popped in
everyone except this thing you said no
seat belts threw me on the floor all of
a sudden i felt like a knee on my back
and on my lower back but the knee on my
upper back was like almost against my
neck so i couldn't breathe
but you know this when you're in a fight
mode
and you got adrenaline i was so out of
it i was still thrashing even though i
got blood drumming down my face right
because my nose is busted and
the security guard is trying to tell me
to calm down i'm still screaming so
they're the handcuffs on me
they lift me up
and at this point i got blood dripping
down my holy standard day is like yo
what the [ __ ] happened and i was so like
i didn't even respond right
so they start they start dragging me
through the mall to go to the arrest
area as i'm there and there's blood
coming down
my dicky pants
i had no belt on so they kept falling so
i was like can you pick up my pants and
he's like [ __ ] you so they're dragging
me through the shopping mall my pants
are on my ankles my blood's coming down
my face cause yo look at it if you got
the oversized dicky pants
okay and you ain't got no belt
you know every three seconds
you're doing that [ __ ]
so they dragging me blood streaming down
my face okay because i i still broke
into the day right
as we pass by the booth of the girl
she's looking at me and i'm looking at
her as they're dragging me because i'm
not even walking
tracking me you can see my boxes in my
thin legs and i look and i'm like am i
seeing you this weekend and she goes
10 minutes early i just got her number
did you call her i did
[Laughter]
here's the thing about young guys you
can go two ways
you can go two ways you can go
incredibly
self-conscious zero confidence or you
could be extremely reckless yeah
young [ __ ] will shoot people for
nothing
so you think i got her number and i
wasn't going to use that [ __ ]
did she did she never responded no of
course not he never responded i was like
hey it's the guy from the mall i don't
know if you wanna
wow yeah he was stupid stupid i was
young
and stupid yeah young dumb and focused
oh i was trying bro like when i said i
took so many l's in my life and some of
the craziest elves
yeah that was a crazy one that's a crazy
one yeah yeah
to this day i was banned from that
shopping mall for years of course yeah
yeah i used to be afraid to go back
there just said i didn't want to get
arrested i went back there as an adult
because you're not a kid anymore you
look different but
man yeah
that's a big old ls that's funny yeah
man i met your dicky pants back then i
had them you had they were not i had
belts
i'm mad at that i always bounce i ain't
mad at that i think it was the people i
hung around with
and
that was it put the belt on put the
dress shirt putting that [ __ ] up i look
like a whole mechanic navy blue
navy blue dicky pants black and beige
i am mad at that black and beige yeah
diggy pants was a [ __ ] yeah yeah so
anyways
just to let you guys know when i say
i've done taking some l's of my life
bruh you guys can't imagine some of the
bad ones
and uh
yeah there's still more
but i say all this to you guys because i
just want to you guys understand a
different mindset even though plenty of
fish existed back then
you just need i was so thirsty yeah
you have to go out there i'm thirsty
right now just trying to relive that
moment you see me sweating you look
thirsty yeah
but i will appreciate that time period
because
it was full of like
i i lacked therefore i took action
and even though those are some
embarrassing stories i appreciate the
fact that i still went out there and
tried and i tried and i tried trying not
to kick the guys out yeah that's why i
wanna
who the guy tried to kick the guy's ass
bro i was i was stupid as a teenager
they dragged me down the stairs they put
me in the holding cell
and then they call uh my dad who comes
to pick me up and the cops come by they
take reports of everything and i
remember being so embarrassed because my
dad had never seen me that kind of
circumstances that's most of us now i
was stupid as a teenager i mean listen
the violent stuff is not to be glorified
like don't don't think i'm saying you're
like oh golden stuff that's stupid
bro the dude had a chain around his hand
he [ __ ] up only my nose but if that
got in the wrong eye socket or something
he could have really done some serious
damage but again
when you're young and reckless you can
get in some stupid situations
you know and at that time i had anger
issues
well i think back to that period
my friend's like yo what's wrong with
you
because my friend's like why didn't you
warn me so i could have like helped or
something that's how crazy i was i don't
even think about nobody else and the
scariest part about being in those
circumstances is that you have no
control
that's why i always laugh at people when
they're like yo why didn't you stop
after the third punch bruh try telling
me no no when you when you when you
try telling me to stop i couldn't even
hear a a security guard who had his knee
on my neck to stop and i was still
trying to kill cause like yo when you
got the testosterone flowing and you got
adrenaline in that too and you got like
emotional issues
it can it can get out of hand super fast
yeah
when you black out yeah it's not cute
yeah
yeah so you know the violent stuff aside
i think when it comes to the more the
approach things it's like it's okay to
be embarrassed it's okay to [ __ ] these
things up um
but yeah you know
go out there and shoot your shot i guess
you still got her number no that's an
old phone
that's over 12 13 14 years ago maybe you
petty like that no no no no i don't know
what she looked like today what's her
name
i don't remember
okay i just took her number and then
messaged her once you think i'm out here
like
oh anissa i don't know
but anyways guys let us know what you
guys think of your comments
comments but we want to hear from you
what do you guys think about that story
what it's just what he meant rough
you're just so embarrassing yo i only
need some food or something maybe once
you get the oh man even when she gave
you the look you still called yeah
because i'm like what do i lose and at
that time that used to be the time where
i didn't know how to take hints
so i would message a girl who was
clearly not interested in me and i
didn't know that until much later when i
reread the logs you ever reread
certainly like damn what was i thinking
when i was messaging
it's like bro you just can't read
science you know but anyways let us know
what you guys think